lost luggage delays it canceled flight
catching a plane can be tiresome for
even the most weathered traveler
enforcing rights can be really difficult
for passengers and a lot of the time we
don't realize when and how to do it in
november parliament will vote to clarify
rules and is set out terms of a
compensation could this be the future
that I student first item is Clyde
Schmidt I now cancellation or in
dagestan teaser that I wounded or you're
off your quad cities dancing only by the
right house in fin hundred kilometer
meter internal flash bedroom Gibson DS
XO not does this kind of iron for whom
the agenda and Pharaoh known point out
ankush the software Mia cloud by the
impostor hearin respecting fundamental
rights the environment and even animals
Parliament's petitions committee is a
tool for citizens to voice their concern
on EU policy every year an annual report
evaluates the work of the committee with
1985 petitions in 2012 how did we do as
the European Parliament we actually
really need to go out and make this more
visible it is very important that the
people understand that they have an
active role and it is on us to show the
people that yes you can participate yes
you have a voice yes you are being heard
any piece made the arguments in favor of
their nominees it was no delicato kofsky
eskinder nega and ray italia more
journalists from ethiopia at the end of
September the candidate to the Sakharov
Prize 2013 will be shortlisted one of
the strongest candidates a 16 year old
pakistani schoolgirl malala yousufzai
she's not only a nominee for this year's
Nobel Peace Prize on cheese issues named
joint winneth analyst internationals
2013 ambassador of conscience award